well let's find out where louisiana
senator john kennedy is on this friday
good morning to you senator where are
you
good morning i'm back in louisiana we're
recovering from the last hurricane
that's right last time you were with us
you didn't have electricity in your neck
of the woods and you had cell service it
was a little spotty but uh folks in that
area now are on the mend and and
drying out and trying to rebuild right
yes we uh we had another hurricane come
through uh nicholas it wasn't as bad as
ida
uh we still got about a hundred thousand
people without electricity um as i've
said before except for new orleans where
the levees hell thank the lord this uh
these last two have been worse than
katrina
but um you know louisianians are tough
as a boot we'll we'll recover
no doubt well senator as as there's a
lot of things going on in our news media
right now take your pick uh afghanistan
books and accusations and things going
on well as that's happening fox news is
busy at work still attempting to cover
what's happening at our southern border
which has gotten no better in fact it's
gotten a lot worse and new images
captured by our drone down there
recently show that over ten thousand
illegals are now basically huddled
underneath a bridge in del rio texas
these are exclusive photos uh that we
have showing this crisis down there yet
senator the faa which is charged with
controlling the airspace is now saying
not so fast no more drones here's what
they said the border patrol requested
the temporary flight restriction due to
drones interfering with law enforcement
flights on the border as with any
temporary flight restriction media is
able to call the fva faa to make
requests
to operate in the area so
due to drones interfering what was
interfering was it the drones
interfering with law enforcement or is
it interfering with the coverage of how
the bio administration wants the border
to be messaging
well it was the coverage look i regret
having to say this
but when it comes to illegal immigration
you just can't trust the biden
administration
uh it would be like trusting uh harvey
weinstein with your daughter
uh when it comes to illegal immigration
uh the bible administration lies like
they breathe they're they're like
they're like time share salesmen i mean
they're peerless
um the truth is that the bad
administration has an open border policy
the truth is that this year we'll have
well over
2 million people
coming into our country allowed in by
the president and we don't have the
slightest idea who they are
and i believe that the reason that
they're
limiting drone usage is because they
don't want the american public
to know
uh and i think this is illegal
and i think they're also misreading the
american people
the american people support
legal immigration that's why we welcome
about a million of our world's neighbors
every year to become american citizens
legally that's more than any other
country in the world
but we do not support illegal
immigration
when you ask the bible administration
about it they say well you're not for
immigration because you're racist
vetting people at the border is not
racist
it's prudent
every country does it
and the american people see the southern
border kind of like they see the front
door of their house
they they don't lock their front door
at night because they want to keep
everybody out they hate everybody on the
outside
the american people lock their front
door at night because they love the
people on the inside and they want to
know who's coming into their home
and and that's what the american people
believe and if you ask the byte
administration what they believe they'll
tell you
the same thing but you have to watch
what they do not what they say and we
now have an open border policy
the uh the the uh the nut jobs are in
charge in the biden administration in
the middle of a pandemic too we hear the
president say
there's a mandate you have to get
vaccinated he's making you and every all
of your colleagues get vaccinated
federal workers have to get vaccinated
or they have to get tested weekly so
it's such it's so hypocritical because
down at the border anyone can come in
and they don't have to get vaccinated
and we're hearing sometimes they're not
even tested
well they don't have to get vaccinated
but
more or as importantly ainsley we we
don't have the slightest idea who they
are
um i'm sure that some are people
who who want to come to america for a
better life that's fine that's
i'm proud of that but that's why we have
a legal immigration system but some of
the people coming in we know
are criminals
uh they're child predators
they're drug dealers
um
they're terrorists
and and the idea of saying um
anybody who wants to come in can come in
is is it's lunacy it's and the american
people don't support it which is why
i think the byte administration is
preventing the usage of the drones and
one of the reasons why there's been such
a surge in del rio is eight days ago the
bidet administration announced they no
longer would
deport haitians back to haiti and so the
haitians who were here i think there
were four thousand on wednesday they got
on the phone they called their loved
ones in haiti and said come on down
because come on up because the border is
wide open
and that is why there is a surge close
to 11 000 under that bridge last night
meanwhile senator let's talk a little
bit go ahead
sure now you go ahead well i was going
to change i was going to change topics
did you want to say one more thing about
that
well i just want to say that that um
the american people aren't racist about
illegal immigration they're just not
having an immigration legal immigration
policy is not racist every country in
the world does it
and having a border wall is not racist
that's why many countries in the world
have a border wall to try to control
immigration but the bible administration
has turned this issue or tried to turn
it into a
a a racial issue like everything else i
guess and and i think the uh
they're misreading and misjudging the
american people
all right meanwhile i was going to
switch over to the fact that later today
the fda advisory committee is going to
meet to figure out whether or not people
who have already gotten the vaccine
should get a booster shot because it
apparently uh helps people but then at
the same time you've got um the
government is buying more of the
monoclonal antibodies uh to avoid
shortages because
the the coronavirus is surging gensake
pointed out yesterday i think that 70
percent of all that stuff is going to
seven different states and your state is
one of them where the delta is a really
big problem right now
um
well
i i think i think that um clearly we we
we're in the midst of of of a surge
i think we have enough vaccine and
enough uh
medicine to treat everybody in america
and to help other people in the world i
believe that
i think that the president's vaccine
mandate has probably
set us back in terms of getting people
vaccinated
the the the president has apparently
decided that that he needs to protect
americans from their dangerous
constitutional rights
apparently the the new rule of the biden
administration is that uh
how can i put this the taliban gets
blackhawks
and the unvaccinated get fired
now that's a hell of a rule
don't don't misunderstand me i i support
the vaccine i've taken the vaccine i
think the vaccine works every one of my
constituents that asked me about it i
tell them that
i tell them the vaccine wasn't developed
by the federal government it was
developed by the private sector the
technology is not new the mrn mrna
technology has been studied for 10 years
but having said that
the president is one part
of our madisonian system of separation
of powers in our federal system and the
president doesn't get just get to say
um everybody has to have a shot
when we confront these issues of
personal freedom versus public safety
which we do all the time
those decisions are made by the people
and they're made at the state level and
at the local level
through the people's elected
representatives
at a minimum they're made by congress
though i don't think congress
really has the say here i think it's up
to the people through their local
representatives it's just like with
lockdowns
um you know some states
like california they think lockdowns
work
i don't i i think we've proven that but
if california wants to lock down they
have they have the authority to do it
the president shouldn't mandate it for
them or anybody else nor should he be
mandating the vaccine i think it's it's
going to cause people not to get the
vaccine we were making some progress in
terms of convincing people to take the
jab and i think this is going to set us
back and i
hate to say it but i think there was a
political element to this too
and senator now it's going to cause
people to lose their jobs because as the
employee mandate kicks in employers are
having to make really difficult
decisions and and whether it's in the
private or the public sector there is a
aurora oregon fire chief who's now suing
oregon his name is josh williams because
he's being mandated uh his his employees
who have not gotten the shot if they
don't get it they're going to be fired
here's what he said on fox news
primetime
i've been an emergency service for 28
years making decisions that impact
people's lives every day i can sure as
hell make a decision what i put my own
body i've made this decision uh
basically what has happened is the state
of oregon has also told me as an
employer
that i cannot employ
a firefighter
or a volunteer firefighter they're
telling me that come october 18th
i have to get rid of those people and
i'm not going to do it and i'm willing
to lose my job over that
so forget about freedom you you're fired
if you don't follow the mandate yeah
well what also disturbs me is that the
implicit message from the bible
administration is that
uh the people who choose not to be
vaccinated
or a bunch of ignorant trump voters who
if they don't get vaccinated deserve to
die that's sort of the implicit message
and that's just simply not true
the the vaccination rate in many of our
inner cities
among many of our minorities in the
country some of whom support republicans
but many of whom support democrats the
vaccination rate is very very low
so if you really break it down and and
look at who's not vaccinated uh many
people who make 50 000 or less are not
vaccinated they're the ones that are
going to be hurt by the president's
policy
now why aren't people taking the vaccine
i think
there are multitude of reasons but one
is
the american people
through bitter experience
have learned not to trust the federal
government
this is not about the vaccine of the
science they don't trust the manager or
elite the wilkeristas in washington and
that's why i tell folks look the federal
government did not make this vaccine the
private sector did
president trump provided the money but
this was not developed by some yahoos
over uh at the department of of health
and social services
or they've had kovid and believe that
natural immunity and the antibodies they
have are as robust as the vaccine as
well which seems to not count why why
won't they count that real quick senator
well we we need a very honest
discussion
led by dr fauci if he's going to still
be running this thing about natural
immunity they don't want to talk about
it but we need to talk about it senator
thank you so much for coming on with us
yup and best of luck down there in
louisiana thank you appreciate it thank
you sir